una capa más de precariedad para una
población extremadamente frágil los
sismos que devastaron parte del sur de
Turquía y el noroeste de Siria dejaron
sin viviendas a miles de refugiados
sirios huyeron de Siria por la guerra
ahora sin alternativas regresan a su
país Pese a que el conflicto todavía
continúa la historia hay problemas en
Siria tú mismo lo sabes pero ahora mismo
el mayor problema está en Turquía en
Siria hay problemas desde hace 12 años
Siria está en ruinas pero ahora mismo la
mayor catástrofe está en Turquía
más de cuatro millones de sirios Residen
en Turquía desde que inició la Guerra en
2011 las regiones asoladas por la
catástrofe acogían a casi 2 millones de
refugiados ankara cambió la normativa de
movilidad de la población refugiada
permitiendo a los sirios que cuentan con
documentos de identidad salir de Turquía
por un periodo de 3 a 6 meses para
reunirse así con sus familias del otro
lado de la frontera
perdí mi casa y desde el terremoto he
estado viviendo en un parque nos dieron
tiendas de campaña pero todo es para
mostrar Así que decidí regresar y vivir
en mi país vivo muerto prefiero estar
con mi familia
otros no podrán regresar bien porque lo
han perdido todo en su nación o por
amenazas de los grupos armados o el
régimen autoritario de bashar al azar
del segmento de sirios refugiados en
Turquía están en el escalafón más bajo
de de la sociedad obviamente más
frágiles con mayor precariedad y con una
situación mucho más complicada no pueden
volver a su casa seguramente su casa
está destruida y sea por la guerra ya
sea por el terremoto y en Turquía en una
situación de absoluta destrucción
también en todo el sur del país pues
obviamente esto añade Mayor Mayor
precariedad y mayor fragilidad económica
más de mil refugiados sirios han
fallecido en los sismos del lado Turco
muchos cuerpos están siendo repatriados
para ser enterrados en sus lugares de
origen